cada cuadrado representa un entero
veamos aquí tengo un entero aquí tengo
otro entero y aquí tengo algo que es
menor a un entero que decimal representa
el área sombreada a ver veamos aquí
tengo un entero aquí tengo otro entero y
aquí tengo un entero que está dividido
en veamos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve diez está dividido en
décimos
por lo que tengo un entero dos enteros a
ver vamos a escribir aquí en dos enteros
y lo que tengo aquí este vamos a ver es
uno dos tres cuatro cuatro décimos
y eso lo puedo escribir como dos enteros
que ya lo puse que son los que tengo y
cuatro décimos pero me están pidiendo
que lo escriben decimales entonces pues
no lo puedo escribir así y para
escribirlo en decimal después escribiría
2 y luego pongo el punto decimal y luego
pongo el 4 ya que el lugar que sigue a
la derecha del punto decimal este que
está aquí es la posición de las décimas
si esta es la posición de las unidades
luego está el punto decimal y luego la
primer posición a la derecha del punto
decimal es el lugar de los décimos
veamos nuestra respuesta
muy bien
bien hagamos otro más
nos preguntan lo mismo y tenemos un
entero dos enteros tres enteros
y aquí tenemos otra vez un entero
dividido en 10 partes iguales 10
secciones horizontales que cada una
representa un décimo a ver veamos 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 efectivamente cada
sección horizontal corresponde a un
décimo entonces tengo tres enteros y 123
3 decimos eso lo escribimos como tres
enteros tres décimos veamos
hagamos otro más bien a ver déjame
acomodar la pantalla bien esta vez
tenemos un entero que está dividido en
veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 hay 10
divisiones en la horizontal y ahora
veamos verticalmente 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 bien entonces tenemos que este
cuadrado está dividido en 10 por 10 son
100 está dividido en centésimos y me
preguntan que decimal representa el área
de color ya sabemos que aquí tenemos
centesimus ahora vamos a contar en cada
una de estas líneas hay 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 aquí tengo 10 20 30 40 50
60 62 centésimos y eso lo escribo como
no tengo unidades pongo el punto decimal
y tengo 62 centésimos bien comprobemos
nuestra respuesta muy bien a ver hagamos
uno más esta vez tenemos un entero que
se ve que está dividido en centésimos
como en el ejercicio anterior y aquí
tenemos otro entero dividido en
centésimos pero el área coloreada sólo
tiene a ver veamos en aquí hay 10 en
esta primera columna 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 10 centésimos y en la siguiente
columna pues sólo falta uno de colorear
así que tenemos 9 centésimos 19
centésimos a ver vamos a escribir un
entero y 19 centésimos si este primer
uno está en el lugar de las décimas y
luego están 9
en el lugar de las centésimas este 19
representa 19 centésimas veamos